florida home of former u.s president
donald trump has been searched by the
fbi the ex-president attacked the raid
as a weaponization of the justice system
the fbi and justice department have
declined to comment as mike hanna
reports from washington
the former president was staying at his
apartment in manhattan when the raid
took place
and was seen leaving trump tower and
walking towards waiting cars
according to the former president his
home in mario largo florida was raided
by a large group of fbi agents who he
alleges also opened the safe in his home
his statement says
after working and cooperating with the
relevant government agencies this
unannounced raid on my home was not
necessary or appropriate
the justice department has declined to
comment on the matter including about
whether attorney general mary garland
had personally authorized the search
previously the national archives and
records administration had referred the
discovery of 15 boxes of classified
information at mario largo to the
justice department for investigation no
former president has faced
a judicial determination that it is
likely that they have committed a crime
judges do not sign off on warrants for
anyone lightly they always believe that
there is likely that a crime has been
committed and that it has been committed
at this specific location so this is
genuinely an unprecedented event
the house january 6 committee which is
investigating the invasion of the
capital on that day
had also heard evidence about the
removal of classified documents when
trump left office
there were also claims that when trump
was president he had repeatedly shredded
or disposed of classified material after
reading it
the destruction or removal of classified
documents to an unauthorized location
is a federal offense
mike hanna al jazeera washington
well richard painter is former chief
ethics lawyer for president george w
bush he says the raid is very
significant
the fbi would not have sought a search
warrant a judge would not have signed
a search warrant if there weren't
probable cause
for the fbi uh to search the premises in
search of
documents that would disclose a serious
crime
and i would think that it wouldn't just
concern the crime of taking uh federal
documents out of the white house
but other crimes as well in particular
the crime of sedition
the attempt to overturn the 2020
election
which uh that plan was going on ever
since uh the election november december
january up to the january six
insurrection after the election his
attempt to overturn the election uh
results uh involved meetings at the
white house talking about sending the
military in to redo the election
pressure put on the justice department
to declare the election invalid the
january 6th insurrection and his role in
that so there was a lot of evidence
that he participated in the attempt to
reverse the election sedition
it's a criminal offense and that
evidence may very well be in those boxes
that were removed from the white house